Speaker 1: I continue to believe that the
people who are currently supporting Donald
Trump are a lost cause.
And we are going to look at some examples.
Donald Trump holding this event yesterday
in Davenport, Iowa, sort of like his first
major campaign event, supposedly a speech
about education, very little about education
was discussed.
Right Side Broadcasting Network was there.
They interviewed people waiting in line.
Here is a guy who explains what he learned
from Tucker Carlson's program over the last
week about the Trump riots.
This I hope you're sitting down for this.
Speaker 2: Let's just keep let's keep that
up there.
Keep it up.
And the people that really did the damage
when they were in Denver.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: There you go.
What this guy learned from Tucker's show is
that the real Trump rioters were not Trump
supporters.
They were Antifa, Antifa folks.
What a stupid country we live in.
I mean, it's just it's gotten humiliatingly
bad here.
It really, really is bad.
And it only gets worse.
I hate to tell you in these interviews.
Here is a woman interviewed at a Trump rally
who says when Trump was president, she didn't
have to worry about the state of the direction
of the world.
Speaker 2: Everything music, entertainment,
sports, pop culture, everything.
I mean, everything.
Yeah, yeah, everything in life touches.
It destroys.
Yep.
I'm glad you guys are here.
Yeah.
The comfortable.
Speaker 8: Feeling that you had when Trump
was there that you don't have.
Speaker 2: To worry about where the world
is.
The meeting was good.
Yeah.
Going down, you know.
Speaker 1: Yeah, there it is.
When Trump was president, she didn't have
to worry.
She just.
He was worry free.
Here is a woman who says that Trump is the
king of the world clearly, to some degree
misunderstanding how our political system
works.
Speaker 2: See the people The Comeback Tour.
Now, Trump is king in Iowa.
He's he's king everywhere.
He's a king everywhere.
All over the.
Speaker 1: World.
Yeah.
The very same people who are afraid of a new
world order.
One world government are cheering Trump as
king of the world.
When asked which traits about Trump folks
in the crowd most missed, the most frequently
cited was Trump's honesty and truthfulness.
As you can remember, that was not the case.
Speaker 2: What do you miss the most about
President Trump?
Truth and honesty.
Yeah.
And honest.
Speaker 8: Being he cares about America.
Speaker 2: He cares.
Speaker 1: Yep.
He truly cares about Americans.
Obviously he doesn't.
And he was really truthful and honest.
He wasn't.
One guy walking in to the rally had some choice
words for right side broadcasting.
Speaker 2: Our newsletter our History network
dot com slash newsletter that we're running
opposite.
Oh don't do that.
Speaker 1: No there is.
And of course the rallying cry of the low
information Midwest Trump supporter a grabber
by the you know what the topic of Ron Desanctis
came up and one woman says the reason she
would not support Desanctis is because he's
funded by George Soros, which is an interesting
combination of conspiracies.
Speaker 2: Is anybody talking about any other
person for president other than Donald Trump?
Any other names?
No, no, no, no.
Speaker 8: I'm talking about Hispanics.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
No, no, no.
Yeah.
And money.
Soros money.
Yeah, there it is.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
DeSantis is bad because he's funded by a George
Soros.
Famously unknown to anyone.
But apparently that's the case.
Here is one other person weighing in about
Ron DeSantis and the possibility of DeSantis
rather than Trump.
Speaker 2: But have you heard anybody else
talk about any other candidate?
DeSantis Yeah, that he's the only one.
You think he has big support here?
I feel like it could go either way to Senator
Trump because Trump's vilified in the state
that knows how to talk to me.
I can see it going either way.
Speaker 1: Very interesting.
So this political analyst believes that it
really could go one way or the other.
Just a couple more of these.
Here's another guy very proudly saying that
he misses Trump's honesty.
Speaker 2: Biggest things you miss about President
Trump, the frankness, the honesty.
Speaker 1: Frankness and the honesty are the
real traits that this gentleman is missing.
And then lastly, here is another woman asked,
What do you want Trump to do about education?
Speaker 2: What are you looking forward to
either seeing and hearing from the president
today?
Just keep talking about Trump.
Yeah.
In terms of education, what would you like
to see him change or improve or suggest.
Speaker 8: Enforce.
Speaker 2: God and patriotism.
Speaker 1: And force God into the school?
Put enforce God and patriotism back into the
schools?
So the folks who chose to go to this event,
Mr. Trump's honesty and truthfulness believe
Antifa death did January 6th and want God
forced back into the schools.
This is what we're up against.
These are people who are not going to go for
Nikki Haley.
Ron DeSantis.
These are Trump people through and through.
And what we can hope is that somehow Trump
loses the primary, runs as an independent,
brings these people with them, splits the
Republican vote and guarantees Democratic
victory in 2024.
We'll have all these clips on our Instagram
as well as on TikTok, as well as on Facebook
and of course, on YouTube to.